it has been one week since Ben Affleck
entered rehab and last night his ex
Jennifer Garner made her first red
carpet appearance
Jennifer rocked his black satin Narciso
Rodriguez dressed for the LA premiere of
her action flick peppermint she becomes
this kind of vigilante fighter coming
back to fight for justice for her
daughter and her husband while the movie
packs a major punch the red carpet
premiere was scaled down no press crews
were invited and Jen only spoke to a
studio hired crew the controlled
environment isn't that surprising since
it was just seven days ago that she
drove her ex Ben Affleck to rehab this
is Ben's third time in rehab tonight
we've learned what may have been the
tipping point for Jen prompting her to
step in a source tells e.t quote Ben was
making excuses for missed plans and
rarely answering his phone in the week
before he entered rehab she knows his
pattern very well and became worried she
went over to check on him fearful of
what she might find and sure enough
found him with empty bottles Troon all
over the house he wreaked of alcohol and
clearly had been on some type of bender
and was in terrible shape within hours
Ben was back in treatment you know you
really hope he can work through his
issues he's such a talented man
[Music]